Last month, Liverpool star Lewis Diaz
and his family suffered
the trauma of his father being kidnaped
and held hostage for 12 days
by rebel Colombian
left wing organization, the L.
One person who reached out to him
at the time
was former Chelsea and Nigeria star Mikel
John Obi. Incredibly, frighteningly.
His father was kidnaped
not once but twice during his career.
And he's been telling CNN's senior
sport analyst Darren Lewis about it.
Because I saw you talked
about empathizing
with Lewis Diaz
after his father was kidnaped.
Your father, Michael, was kidnaped twice.
Can you talk us through
what happened the first time?
Yeah, He finished work
and he was going home, driving home
with his driver.
And, you know, they pulled
they got pulled over.
They got pulled over a car,
went in front of them.
They they got pulled over.
And yeah, he was taken
I think he was
taken for about ten days.
And and that's when, you know,
we're trying to.
Started making phone calls
and they got in touch with us.
Obviously, they wanted to speak with me.
So
so I spoke with them.
They made their demands.
I spoke to the club.
I spoke to Roman.
Michael, what were their demands?
And the demands?
Demands sought
to pay a huge amount of money.
You know that if I don't pay,
my dad will not be released.
That they're going to shoot my dad.
They're going to kill him if I don't pay.
They know I have the money.
So if I want to see my dad again,
I have to make sure that I,
that I, that I bring the money.
I did speak
to the club, and Roman offered his help.
If you need me to. To to do anything.
If you need me to get
to send my people over to Nigeria
to find your dad,
I'd be willing to do that.
You know, you have that option.
But if you think you,
you, you,
you will pay the money, then you do.
So I finally had to pay the money.
And then my dad got released. Yeah.
And that was the first time. Yeah.
So that was heartbreak.
That was a heartbreaking moment.
To be reunited.
What would that have been like?
Oh, that was.
Yeah, Yeah. No.
Yeah, No, that was tough.
You know,
See your dad come out, come out.
You know, picture that up from from,
you know, from the street.
You know, where he was dumped.
And they tell you, go there and pick up
your dad like it's a trash, you know,
bruised, beaten up
lips broken
everywhere, had swollen,
you know, things like that.
Can't walk, can't move.
It was a very heartbreaking moment for me
and my family.
So for me,
when it happened again the second time,
you know, it was even harder.
It was even much, much
difficult to deal with.
How did it happen the second time?
A second
time was obviously
I was with the national team
at the World Cup 2018.
We're about to play against Argentina
in the knockout stages,
you know, just as everybody else.
I was excited
that, you know,
going into one of the biggest game
of my
of my life, playing
against Massey Energy and TNA,
I remember speaking to my mom
before the game.
She was like,
no, you can go out and perform.
You can't.
You're not in the right.
You can't perform, you can't play.
I was like, Mom, I'm the captain.
I'm the leader.
I have to go out there
and show a bit of strength.
I have to go out there, be strong.
And that's exactly what I did.
And unfortunately,
we didn't win the game.
But yeah, I remember a few times
I thought I was going to.
I thought I was going to show up.
I thought I was going to fall down
and probably collapse or something.
So when that happened to Diaz,
I definitely knew
what he was going through
as somebody who's been in that situation.
And that's why I reached out
and I showed my support
because I definitely knew
exactly how he was feeling.
You said that you reached out to Luis.
Are you able to give us
any kind of insight into the conversation
that you had.
No idea really have a
conversation with him?
I just you know, obviously,
I just showed my support,
you know,
my support on social media
saying how, you know, what I
you know, how I feel.
And and
I definitely know
exactly what he's going through.
You know, it's a difficult moment.
Again, I have to,
you know, commend him and Liverpool,
I can always say
when you in this situations
you need people around
you need people who care about you.
And Liverpool showed their support.
And I'm happy to see that
that's what he got with Liverpool and
and eventually,
you know, he's that finally got released.